Speaker 1: Well, my friends, inflation is down
significantly and Joe Biden's approval rating
continues to climb in a horrible turn of events
for the right, which wants to continue to tell
the lie that Democratic presidents are terrible
for the economy. Now, you all know that I don't
actually play these games when it comes to the
economy. You all know that when we talk like this,
it's sort of tongue in cheek, because the reality
is that on many of these issues, presidents have
very little influence one way or the other.
I don't play the gas prices game. I will
jokingly say, how did Joe Biden get gas prices
to be down a dollar 70 per gallon as they are?
But of course, I don't really give him credit
for that. The same way that I don't blame him
for the fact that gas prices went up. But for
the right wingers that see the world in this way,
we should be aware of what is going on. And
as I'm an idiot when it comes to this stuff,
but I predicted we would get down into the sixes
in the first part of 2023 and inflation would
probably be down into the four or fives by the
middle or third quarter of 2023. And we continue
to go in that direction. We learned this morning
CNBC report consumer prices fell 0.1% in December
in line with expectations. Excluding food and
energy, core CPI rose 0.3% on an annual basis.
Headline CPI, meaning top line inflation, is now
up 6.5%, while core inflation is up 5.7%. The
biggest reason for the easing in inflation
came from a sharp drop in gasoline prices,
which are now lower on a year over year basis.
I want to tell everybody again, because people
are so confused and they write to me things
that make no sense. When we talk about 6.5%,
what we're talking about is over the last year. So
we just got the December numbers. So when we now
say year over year, we're talking about price
increase from December 2021 to December 2022.
Every month you shift by one month. What is the 12
month period we're talking about? So in December,
when we got the November number, we were talking
about inflation from November 21 to November 22.
It's now January. We've now added the December
22 inflation data and removed the November 21.
So we've changed the range Instead of November 21
to November 22. We're now talking about December
21 to December 22. That inflation number is down
from being in the eights to 6.5%. That is what
we are talking about when we talk about inflation.
This is now six months in a row that inflation has
come down. Core inflation from October to December
was only 3.1% annualized. That's the lowest such
reading in 15 months. Gas, as I mentioned,
is down a dollar 70 per gallon from its peak.
Food inflation is slowing. Last month we saw
actually the smallest increase in food prices
in almost two years. The cost of goods is falling
for electronics. Used car prices have come down,
which got completely out of control. Wages are
higher now than six months ago, so it's not.
Prices are coming down and so are wages. Wages
are still higher, prices are lower when you adjust
everything for inflation. We have the lowest
unemployment rate in 50 years and it is at least
partially being perceived by voters as Joe Biden
being a generally good steward of the economy. You
don't have to believe, as I don't believe, that
every one of these numbers is related to who's
president. I didn't believe it under Trump, and I
don't believe it's the case under Biden. I'm not
playing games with that. But when you see the
zoomed out version of what's happening in the
country, you see a pretty steady uptrend in Joe
Biden's approval, which bottomed out in late July.
And as you if you're looking on the screen,
it's been up, up, up. And there's a new
little uptick here even in the last week where
Joe Biden's approval is now up to 44%. Now,
you might say 44%. That's terrible. Yeah. I
mean, listen, the point here is. In the modern,
hyper polarized climate of American politics. You
look at Bush, Obama and Trump approvals over time,
44% at this point in one's term is actually just
fine. It's uncontroversial is the point. The idea
that the country is furious and disgusted with
Joe Biden, it's just not borne out in the data.
So skip the David, you're a Democratic shill
stuff. I've never been a registered Democrat. I
don't care about Joe Biden. I don't care about
the Democratic Party. What I'm coming to you
and saying is the American people are realizing
that what Republicans are offering is nonsense.
If you look at the Republican priorities that
have been made clear since they took over the
House of Representatives very recently, their
ideas benefit the super wealthy. They want to
essentially help the wealthy avoid taxes at the
expense of ordinary middle class taxpayers. House
Republicans introduced a bill to block actions
that would lower gas prices. They gutted a bunch
of ethics requirements. They are pushing a bill
that would actually increase tax rates on middle
class families at the net effective level.
And they're open to open to cuts to Social
Security and Medicare. That's what Republicans
are offering now. Hopefully, they won't get any
of it done because the Republicans don't control
the Senate. But inflation numbers improving. Very
good economic numbers. You see what Republicans
are offering. It makes sense that Joe Biden's
approval keeps ticking up. And quite frankly,
18 months ago, yeah, 12 months ago, roughly,
I would not have said Joe Biden is
well-positioned for reelection in 2024.
Right now, I think Joe Biden is dramatically
better positioned for reelection. Doesn't mean
he is running or should run or shouldn't run,
but just based on the data, the economy is
quite strong and that tends to bode well when
presidents argue for their own reelection.